a new report says that one in five
millionaire CEOs may actually be
Psychopaths this is a report coming from
our article coming from CNBC and listen
at face value I think it's really self
explanatory not a real need for me to go
in-depth when you consider millionaires
in America but I want to read directly
from the article they say quote
millionaires are actually millionaires
often crave validation and recognition
from others this is primarily because of
their self-esteem is high but fragile
bosses who constantly show off are
probably desperate for others admiration
number two they tend to be self-centered
this means they generally are less
interested in others and have deficits
in empathy for this reason they are
rarely found displaying any genuine
consideration for people other than
themselves and number three they have
high levels of entitlement narcissists
commonly have behaved as if they deserve
certain privileges or enjoy higher
status than their peers enjoy so those
are three traits that are inside of the
article that explains why one a 5
millionaire CEOs may be psychopaths the
the flipside of this is that they also
this article also tries to explain that
this is not necessarily a horrible thing
it's just sort of the way it goes
especially when you think about super
successful individuals they use an
example of Steve Jobs while he was able
to do all these magnificent things he
was very harmful to his to are treated
his employees very terribly of parking
you know these example him parking in
the handicap spot which you know and in
the treatment of his subordinates giving
those examples and they of course they
brought up Elon Musk who we can all see
probably fits this mode very well they
also brought up examples of just regular
people who may not be millionaires or
CEOs but they have a dichotomy you know
on one side they use an example of a
firefighter who did some amazing
rescuing of of individuals when he was
off work and then turn around he got
busted in a hundred million dollar
cocaine ring so it just you know they're
trying to explain it away as saying well
the fact that
they may be Psychopaths is maybe
troubling but also this is sort of the
nature of high-performing individuals I
I don't know so much about that
explanation I think the explanation is
BS but what I do know is that I'm not
surprised or actually rather I'm
surprised the percentage isn't higher
right working with I don't you know what
I honestly don't have to explain this
any further
every single one of you who has worked
with the CEO of your company right
you see traits that that actually are
rewarded in America there it is that's
what we'll talk about they're rewarded
that the behavior patterns that are
rewarded in America are behavior
patterns that lean towards narcissism
and lean towards megalomania and right
in lean turns towards the lack of
empathy in fact the more empathy that
you have in certain corporate settings
the less likely you are to move up
because you have to be willing to play
at a cut-throat level just to get ahead
right that's that's simply the fact of
life in quite a few corporate structures
not every corporation is like that I've
been in some environments that are quite
the opposite but I've also been in
environments in which this behavior that
they're describing is is malignant like
this is literally describing people that
I've worked with who whether or not
they're millionaires remains to be seen
but I mean the level of narcissism the
level of entitlement and the ability to
mobilize that and present oneself or
actually not mobilize that the ability
to capitalize on that megalomania and
convince the rest of the world that
we're really just good people out here
trying to do good right
public relations like PR publicist man
there they are they are the master
propagandists because they're able to
take a person who quite literally needs
medical attention right who treats
people as subhuman who will step on
anyone to get where they need to go and
they will make them look as though they
are the most noble people in our society
that's what they do and it's not just
their fault it's also America's fault in
general because we reward this type of
behavior time and time again no one's
really going to get a get rewarded for
being the kindest person in corporate
America or being the most empathetic now
the person who gets rewarded who gets a
promotion who gets the who gets to be
the CEO is the person who's literally
willing to step on whoever the hell they
have to step on to get where they want
to go so I'm not surprised by this
report except for the fact that I would
think it would be more than 20% of
millionaires I don't know I'm thinking I
think in the majority of millionaires
CEOs in this environment in this in this
capitalistic environment have crushed
quite a few people to get their way to
the top they just look sanitized because
of good public relations